Déjenme explicar qué quiero decir con ''erróneamente''.
Puede que le pregunten: ''¿Tienes SPM''?
y ella diga que sí,
pero entonces, cuando pides que registre diariamente
los síntomas psicológicos por dos meses,
no existe correlación alguna entre sus síntomas
y el momento del mes.
Otra razón por la que persiste el mito del SPM
está relacionada con la importante limitación del rol femenino.
Psicólogas feministas como Joan Chrisler
han sugerido que con la etiqueta del SPM se pueden expresar
de una forma que, que de otra manera,
podría considerarse impropia de señoras.
La definición casi universal de la buena mujer
es aquella que es feliz, cariñosa, comprensiva con los demás,
y que se siente satisfecha de tener este papel.
El SPM se ha convertido en el permiso
para estar enfadada, irritada o para quejarse,
sin por ello perder el título de buena mujer.
Sabemos que es más probable que las variables alrededor de una mujer
la hagan enfadarse que sus hormonas,
pero cuando ella atribuye su enfado a las hormonas,
es absuelta de responsabilidad o crítica.
''No es ella realmente. Está fuera de control''.
Y aunque pueda ser una herramienta útil, también sirve para invalidar sus emociones
Cuando la gente responde al enfado de una mujer
pensando: ''Es solo ese momento del mes'',
su capacidad para ser tomada en serio
o efectuar cambios se limita seriamente.
Así que ¿quién más se beneficia del mito del SPM?
Puedo decirles que el tratamiento para el SPM
se ha convertido en una industria próspera y rentable.
Actualmente, ''Amazon.com'' ofrece más de 1 900 libros sobre su tratamiento.
Una rápida búsqueda en Google devolverá una gran cantidad
de clínicas, talleres y seminarios.
Prestigiosas fuentes de Internet de información médica,
como WebMD o la Mayo Clinic
registra el SPM en la lista de trastornos conocidos.
No es un trastorno conocido, pero lo incluyen.
Y también anotan los fármacos que los médicos han prescrito
para tratarlo, como antidepresivos u hormonas.
Curiosamente, ambas webs afirman, sin embargo, que el éxito de la medicación
al tratar los síntomas del SPM varían de una mujer a otra.
Bien, eso no tiene sentido.
Si se trata de un trastorno claro con una causa clara,
como supuestamente lo es el SPM,
entonces el tratamiento debería aliviar
a un elevado número de mujeres.
No ha sido el caso de estos tratamientos,
y la normativa de la FDA expone que, para que un fármaco se considere efectivo,
una gran parte de la población meta
debería tener una mejoría clínicamente significativa.
Y eso no ha sucedido, en absoluto, con estos supuestos tratamientos.
Sin embargo, los beneficios económicos de perpetuar el mito
de que el SPM es un trastorno mental común
y de que es tratable, son bastante importantes.
Cuando se prescribe a mujeres
medicamentos como antidepresivos u hormonas,
el protocolo médico exige que se realice un seguimiento médico cada 3 meses.
Eso son muchas visitas al médico.
Las compañías farmacéuticas obtienen beneficios incalculables
cuando las mujeres creen que deben tomar un medicamento
durante toda su vida reproductiva.
Medicamentos sin receta como Midol
aseguran incluso tratar síntomas del SPM como la tensión y la irritabilidad,
aunque solo contengan un diurético, un analgésico
y cafeína.
No es que yo quiera discutir los poderes mágicos de la cafeína,
pero reducir la tensión no es uno de ellos.
Desde 2002, Midol ha puesto a la venta Teen Midol para las adolescentes.
Se dirigen a muchachas jóvenes
para convencerlas de que todas tienen el SPM y de que las hará monstruos,
pero, espera, hay algo que puedes hacer:
Toma Midol y volverás a ser humana.
En 2013, Midol ingresó casi 45 millones de dólares en ventas.
Si el perpetuar el mito ha sido lucrativo para algunos,
esto entraña algunas consecuencias serias para las mujeres.
Primero, contribuye a la medicalización
de la salud reproductiva de la mujer.
El ámbito médico tiene experiencia a la hora de conceptualizar
procesos reproductivos femeninos como enfermedades tratables,
y esto ha supuesto grandes costes, incluso demasiadas cesáreas,
histerectomías y tratamientos hormonales prescritos
que más que mejorarla han dañado la salud de la mujer.
Segundo, el mito del SPM también contribuye al estereotipo
de que las mujeres son irracionales y demasiado sensibles.
Cuando el periodo menstrual se describe como montaña rusa hormonal
que convierte a las mujeres en fieras iracundas,
es fácil cuestionar la capacidad de todas las mujeres.
Las mujeres han dado grandes zancadas en el mundo laboral,
pero aún es minúsculo el número de ellas en las altas esferas
en ámbitos como el gobierno o los negocios,
y cuando pensamos en la figura de un buen director ejecutivo o senador,
alguien con cualidades como la racionalidad, la constancia
o la competencia se nos vienen a la cabeza,
y en nuestra cultura, eso suena más a hombre que a mujer;
y el mito del SPM contribuye a ello.
Los psicólogos saben que el humor de hombres y mujeres
es más parecido que diferente.
Un estudio analizó a hombres y mujeres entre 4 y 6 meses
y reveló que el número de cambios de humor que tuvieron
y la severidad de esos cambios de humor eran los mismos.
Y, por último, el mito del SPM impide a las mujeres tratar con
los asuntos que de verdad les provocan malestar emocional.
Cuestiones como la calidad de las relaciones o las condiciones laborales
o temas sociales como el racismo, el sexismo o el yugo cotidiano de la pobreza
están muy relacionadas con el humor diario.
Meter las emociones bajo la alfombra del SPM
impide a las mujeres entender la causa de sus emociones negativas,
pero también les quita la oportunidad de hacer algo para cambiarlas.
Así que la buena noticia sobre el SPM
es que, aunque algunas mujeres tienen síntomas por su ciclo menstrual,
la gran mayoría no tiene ningún trastorno mental.
Van al trabajo o a la escuela, cuidan de sus familias,
y llevan una vida normal.
Sabemos que las emociones y el humor de hombres y mujeres
son más parecidos que diferentes,
así que dejemos el cansino y anticuado mito del SPM sobre las mujeres-brujas
y acojamos la realidad de una actividad altamente emotiva y profesional
desempeñada por la mayoría de las mujeres cada día.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)